the reason Trump is triggered about
Biden running again is
Biden beat him in 2020. and Trump no
matter what he says publicly knows if he
beat me in 2020 he could beat me again
and the question for Trump is given that
he lost in 2020
how can he gain ground on Joe Biden in
2024 Trump's arrest and indictment May
well help him with Republican voters
it's not helping him in the general
election and so the mathematical problem
for Trump is you look at the map and you
look at the results of 2020 then you say
well you know a lot of these states
Arizona certainly hasn't moved to the
right since 2020. Wisconsin hasn't moved
to the right since 2020 Florida has but
Trump won Florida so that doesn't get
him any additional electoral votes so
Trump realizes it's a difficult map